all right here's a headline from the
daily wire
gay couple allegedly pimped out and made
child porn with adopted children
this is a very difficult story to read
it's
one of the most horrifying
news stories
I've ever seen
but here is the uh the story anyway a
shocking investigation has reportedly
uncovered disturbing new details about a
gay activist couple in Georgia who are
charged with raping their adopted sons
and pimping them out to a local lgbtq
pedophile ring
a month-long Town Hall Town Hall
investigation published Tuesday viewed
recorded Jailhouse calls and new court
documents and spoke exclusively to a
family member revealing that the alleged
sexual abuse went much deeper than
previously reported the investigation
will have three more installments
according to the town hall the married
couple William Dale zulock Jr 33 is a
government worker his husband Zachary
Jacoby zulak 35 a banker
were arrested last summer on charges of
sodomizing their two Elementary age sons
and prostituting the children
they were indicted by a grand jury on
charges of incest aggravated sodomy
aggravated child molestation felony
sexual exploitation of children and
felony prostitution of a minor if
convicted they faced more than nine life
sentences each both men have pleaded not
guilty
um
let me get into some of the details the
zoo locks adopted the brothers now 9-11
from a Christian special needs adoption
agency
before they arrest the couple lived in
affluent life in Oxford Georgia and
Atlanta suburb the children were
enrolled in third and fourth grade when
their um
adoptive fathers were arrested according
to a 17 count indictment the two men
allegedly performed oral sex on both
their adoptive Sons forced the boys to
perform oral sex on them
they raped their sons anally at least
once the older boy was allegedly injured
from
the rape the sexual abuse allegedly
began in late 2019 and began became
worse in 2021
Williams has since admitted to forcing
his 11 year old son to perform oral
copulation on him
David he admitted this
I can't even keep reading this uh
it's an important report from town hall
and you can go and you can and this is
as I said there are multiple
installments of it uh and and it it's
it's good that town hall is following
this story
the daily wire is following it
because we know that this is the kind of
story that uh the corporate media is not
interested in uh they
uh
this is not something they want to talk
about
especially when you I mean it's it's bad
enough for their narrative anyway uh
that the culprits here uh are is a gay
couple but then also when you when you
add in this LGBT pedophile ring
um that just makes it all the more
certain that the corporate media is not
going to want to talk about this
what can we say about it well to begin
with public execution for both should be
the the penalty uh I just think every
time I read
someone who does something horrific like
this and then they get charged with
multiple life sentences
every time I read that it
it makes me Furious
not only because of what they've done of
course but just the the absurdity this
charade of giving what the hell multiple
life sentences
as if that's supposed to oh no now we're
really serious life in prison isn't
enough so we all acknowledge that life
in prison isn't enough for these demons
and so we're not just gonna give him
light prison we're gonna give him nine
lives in prison well if they were cats
then maybe that would mean something but
they're human beings and so they only
have one life to live and you're not
making the sentence any harsher by
adding on life sentences it's totally
symbolic and I think it's a it's a it's
a grotesque just mockery of Justice
because what they should be doing if you
are admitting
if the justice system the court system
is admitting that a life sentence is not
enough of a punishment which it isn't
then there's only one other step up and
it's not to add on well if we'll give
them not we'll give them 50 life
sentences that'll show them
no if the one life sentence is not
enough of a punishment and we all seem
to agree that it's not
then the next step is execution
um
and it should be done publicly and it
should be done pretty quickly
charge them you can victim they're
convicted uh you you take them out you
take them out back shortly thereafter
you parade them out you pray them out in
front of a crowd
you want a crowd there
because we want them to know that this
final disgrace of them being killed we
want them to know that it's being seen
we want them to know that
we want them to have that additional bit
of suffering
we want all the we want all the
suffering for them possible we want to
cause them immense suffering
because that's Justice
and we also want Society to see that we
want Society to see this is how we this
is what we do with people who treat kids
this way
anyone else in the LGBT pedophile ring
when we find you this is what we're
going to do to you
so that's what it should be
first of all
and the second point is that this is not
uh surprising this is horrifying it's
infuriating it's evil it's uh nauseating
it's disgusting it's a lot of things
um
but it's not surprising
you're putting children into a
disordered environment
and when you do that you can't be
surprised
by the horrible things that follow
look children need a mom and a dad
that's what children need they need a
mom and a dad children every child has a
mom and a dad
um every child biologically has a mother
and father not every child has a mother
and father who are willing to or able to
care for them
for whatever reason
and so does that mean that we say well
uh
you know your first your first your
biological set of mother and father
didn't work out so we're just gonna so
that whole arrangement we don't you
don't need that
we'll do something else for you know
we'll give you two dads or two moms or
one mom or whatever you know it's fine
you'll settle you'll settle for
something else
uh
that cannot be the solution
now yes is it if you
can mother father couples can they abuse
their children does that happen of
course it does
but you want to give kids the best
chance possible
you want to put them in the most ideal
possible situation to start with
and horrific things will still happen
even when you do that we all know that
that's one of the that's just that's one
of the terrible things about living in a
fallen world but you still want to give
kids the best chance possible
which means you give them a mother and a
father
and by the way you know and I made this
point on on Twitter and uh there were
people pretending as always
to be offended by it
um and yet as always you know I say this
and most other people they listen it's
like they know that I'm right even if
they won't say it out loud and um the
point is that I would not
I would I would not hire a man
to babysit my kids for two hours so that
my wife and I can go out for dinner I
would never do that now
if there's a man who's a close family
member a close friend who I who I know
very well and Trust
it's obviously different
but I would not hire when it comes to
like hiring a babysitter
someone you don't really know and you're
hiring someone this is what they do for
a job and you're bringing them in to
watch your kids I wouldn't hire a man
for that
and almost no parent would or ever has
so they could hear that and say oh
that's I I don't well no almost no
parent would
you know you go on some babysitter
service and you you know you're looking
for a nanny service or whatever it is uh
and there's a lot of them out there
and you're looking for someone to care
for your kids uh if you see a man's
profile come up you're scrolling right
past that one almost everyone does
because again it's about it's about
putting your kid in any situation in the
most ideal possible situation
you're playing the odds you're looking
at statistics
and so
you know almost no one would hire a male
babysitter to babysit their kids
and yet we're we're giving male couples
kids to adopt
does that make sense
like would you have hired these two guys
to come watch your kids for a night if
you were on let's say you're on a you
know babies nanny service or something
someone's recommended to you maybe
so you need a babysitter they said who
you got and then they named these two 30
year old men
would you like would you say okay y'all
haven't come babysit my kids for three
hours
almost nobody would
but they admitted out loud or not
and yet we're giving or adopting kids
out to them
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as you move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not we'll
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]